thank you so much everybody and thank
you feel but for what you've said and
what he gave me he has already said what
I wanted to say first that today it's my
daughter's ear is birthday which is a
strange coincidence so allow me to say
Dilys born on yourself cause I'm very
grateful to the members of the Academy
for accepting me as a new member and
this totally unexpected Roscoe I think
at the moment here tonight about some of
the great directors I have been working
with and who have already passed away
like Lisbon well of course Jacques Tati
women Patricia who Nagisa Oshima knocked
off already
Jacques Attali they all taught me
something each of them and they are
always present even today even now in
this moment when I'm working and when
when I hear I believe I hear their
voices in my ears in a way they are all
here tonight with us and of course I
think also about the directors was still
alive like that one and like ever
careened off that you saw in the film
like me or Foreman of course like Peter
Brooke was going to turn 90 pretty soon
and still very much alive and working so
that's all I wanted to say we a
screenwriter is nothing without a
director and with such directors as the
ones I have been happy to work with it's
it's a gift it's just a series of gifts
now I'm also to say something about the
fact that this Oscar goes to a
screenwriter and I'm very happy of this
because very often the screenwriters are
are forgotten
ignore there are like shadows passing
through history of cinema their names
and do not appear in the reviews very
sad no but still there are filmmakers
that's why tonight I like to share this
priceless least statue with all my
colleagues the ones I know the ones I
don't know from all over the world to
share with them so we all thank you